then
okay hello everyone we are continuing a
meeting actually from yesterday about
the future of arrays and related objects
in wolfram language and yesterday we had
talked a whole bunch about data
containers
or scaffolded arrays
or possibly extensions to dataset
that are ways of efficiently storing
um
structured
uh collections of data so just to define
what we're talking about there again
i think we're primarily looking at
rectangular ish
arrays possibly with missings in do we
agree
yes yes i think
i think it's lists
and associations with missings and i'm
still hoping we can handle ruggedness
because it's going to be very important
for dataset
okay all right so let's let's just
summarize what the
you know
the objectives here yes
maybe another point at least last time i
think that the idea was sort of that
there'd be
there'd be different sub implementations
of special cases which would have their
own heads and then there'd be a grand
kind of unified head which would
basically pick an implementation and
that's the one that would support lots
of stuff but the individual smaller
heads wouldn't be so flexible
okay that's a sensible idea all right so
look objectives
um
large
um
rectangular
ish
data
um stored so typically
typically
stored in a
nested uh associations and lists
okay so then
we want to be able to do um
then
sub cases
for different you know storage
uh
etc mechanisms
so the sub cases that we know so one
subcase there
eg
cases that work in relational databases
that right
is that right
yes that is the two-level case right
and
then we have
or or
you mean basic column based arrays
yes i e
which i think is a little different from
relational databases but
well okay row plus column
arrays
um
now
okay so so then
uh
the data
can contain
remote assets
i i don't know whether that's something
that would in other words that's the
case where we're dealing with
remote potentially out of core assets
that are mostly handled as single blobs
like a giant image for example
does that make sense
i mean that's a slightly different
mechanism something that we might be
useful in general
i mean isn't it the case
isn't it case that the data
has some uniformity like going down a
column everything is a date
or yes
or i think that's an important point
somehow right that's what i'm saying
rectangular-ish arrays
with consistent data types consistent
data types in a given dimension
is that what we are basically saying
given i think it's no no it's not in the
dimension that's with a given end for a
given index like if it's ijkl the k
index
in a given
dimension slash index slash direction
whatever you want to call it i i think
we know what that means
i think well if you've got a better name
for it tell me
i'm i'm saying this is a good name i'm
i'm
okay all right fine okay but so so now
um
okay they can there can be
there can be missings
um
and
okay so this this remote assets thing
which is basically you know the mongodb
story
right
i'm not sure about what you mean by that
like you mean that
aren't there many
there are many
potential back-ends including arrow and
other things right no i know but this is
a particular okay let me let me list
this separately
i mean this is
this is
remote assets
um and so the what i mean by that is
like for machine learning training
you've got
a hundred thousand
okay
the the hundred thousand backbone
is something where you can group them
into
you know pictures of dogs pictures of
cats you're just manipulating the
backbone okay each image is 50 megabytes
let's say
okay so but you are most of the
computations you're doing are on the
backbone you only dip down to the 50
megabyte image occasionally am i making
sense
yeah but i think you are making it more
uh abstract than what it is in the end
it's just a database of uh uh
properties names
and and you work on the databases and
one one value is the url where the real
image is okay so i mean in this case a
remote asset is just a link
yes i understand
okay but let me understand this
it was my understanding that our mongodb
implementation which is fairly extensive
right was not the same thing that is not
something we can use
for
okay contrast for me
what we have
with mongodb
do you understand what i'm saying
contrast what we can do with this with
what we can do with sql
so the difference is that mongodb is
document based and can be arbitrarily
nested
it's it has i mean
it's on you to enforce a schema so if
you want i mean maybe there is a strict
mode but in general a mongodb
document based database can have
arbitrarily nested stuff and it doesn't
have to be uniform in time
okay
also
it can be ragged and it's not tables
okay all right fine and then there is
there is another big difference in that
for sql we have a full-fledged compiler
from the high-level wall from language
while for mongodb it has its own
language which is pretty low level and
we don't have any kind of compilation
step from okay all right okay okay so
javascript isn't it
uh i who knows what it is
no it's not it's json formed in a
certain way
okay so so let's look then
at
you know
this is that we have a list here
of
uh okay this is where we talked about
remote asset arrays so we've also got
you know can
yeah
uh sorry i mean
one of the things
we talked about is you know
the
all all the little sub heads will need
to implement some sort of
you know basic api but we haven't
specified what that api is i know we're
going to get to that okay let's make a
list first of all of possible backends
okay so one is in memory expressions
okay another would be
i'm just making a general list cloud
expression might be a back end do we
agree or do we not agree
well i i haven't seen the new cloud
expression the old cloud expression i
don't think was
really useful for much of anything right
the new cloud expression is a fine thing
that does what it does
okay that she does it properly
so
more than they can you mean like the
place where the data leaves
i guess i mean that as well but let's
keep going because
there's the place and there's the the
format right i mean there's that right
um
there's also places
okay so hold on places
and
formats
but and also maybe there's there's
there's what the the front end structure
looks like versus the back end right i
mean there might be things that have a
similar you know they're both lists of
associations but they they have
different implementations yeah okay okay
okay so so then it's then the next okay
so we've got really a table of
information here we've got
where
where is it
what
is its
native format
um what is its expression
like it's expression like you know it's
ex expression version you know is
expressed serialization yeah expression
format you know
plus serialization
okay so what we've got here
so one other thing that's that's come up
and i think that
so this is by far from the last of these
storage systems that we're going to be
designing
is that
a lot of operations have moved closer to
data so some you know what used to be
like a pure storage system with some
easy lookup is storage plus computation
so
yeah yeah right i know i understand so
that means that's why we're doing you
know our postgres database that geo
lookups is being done on the database
not in the language for example for
example
right so
i agree that that okay so
so and and our basic strategy
you know our strategy
is typically
is is now is typically
um
you know make a compiler
from
uh language level queries
from wl queries
to native queries
so that these can be done closer to the
data
is that right
yes i think that's a very important
point
okay so let's make a list then
of of general
okay well let's let's okay general
technologies let's start off with that
okay
um
okay so we've got
we've got you know
uh
you know we've got sort of the in memory
we've got
the
uh
we've got cloud expression
which is otherwise known as i mean i
don't know what that technology actually
okay i'm sorry when you say that you
mean our cloud
yes i mean our cloud so i mean sql
because we could you know we could you
know we when we should use other clouds
too we do we do that's exactly what
external storage is doing yeah okay but
external storage so here's here's a
piece we don't have
external storage is just buckets it's
just like storing
expressions right cloud expression
allows us
to um here
we can do operations on the expression
in the cloud
without going into memory
see what i'm saying it's a wolfram
language that's local there in other
system there might be another local
language indeed that's not as general
yeah right that's exactly what the
business different storage systems you
know if you look at aws offering they
have a variety of storage systems and i
swear that they introduce another one
every year
well okay so we support some of these in
external storage
that's what external storage does and
external storage right now is supporting
things like aws azure
uh you know ipfs things like this
right because within those those worlds
there are whole different s3 is totally
different from some of their others no
no i understand roger i understand so my
point here okay so what the point that
you're making is we could imagine making
a cloud expression for aws
right right so so
you know there's a there's a thing here
i don't want to sort of i don't want to
grasp too much i want to but i also
don't want us to unnecessarily limit
ourselves okay fine but
we're just trying to list general
technologies here so document databases
i would add the laser based on streaming
as well well yes you're right i was
going to add that yep
okay i mean streaming streaming is a
thing whether they're a laser list or
not
yeah files
and that could be like csv it could be
hdf it could be binary well the
difference really is that lazy list is
kind of built on the idea of streaming
and represents a list like interface
which is lazy
uh but streaming on its own doesn't have
to be lazy list it can be just you know
chunks of things that you consume
hold on streaming is an operation
streaming interface
for audio and video we definitely have
streaming interfaces and there is so
streaming
streaming onto
files etc etc
in other words streaming is a type of
interface that can be applied to a
variety of external storage media
correct
is that correct or is that not correct i
think it's correct yeah and lazy one
thing
yeah well maybe one thing to note is
also just that the uh
lazy list and streaming are are more
uh or maybe more natural for sort of
data and less big rectangular data
so let's note here
this is
1d
oops
this is and that's a 1d story
uh
well
i would just say that laser lists in
general the the chunks of things that
you are lazily fetching can themselves
be
uh things like multi-dimensional all
right fine but it's basically being
processed
in a single one-dimensional list oh yes
right right so
each row at a time
right whereas sql is 2d
you know
in some sense that's its name
come on that's its native form you can
do all kinds of standing on your head
but its native form is rows and columns
yeah but the the point is that basic
basic sql is rory entered and so it's
it's processed as a list of associations
whereas some of the
sql-like things that are for data
science are columnar and so they're
processed in the other doesn't matter
basically we're talking about rows and
columns which is different from what
we're talking about for for
you know i think i think leonid stuff
gets low it can do a list of
associations yes i'm sure it can i'm
sure it can but it's not doing
operations that are columnar operations
on those things is it actually steven i
beg to differ here because i think lazy
list is more like an interface and it
basically compiles the queries down to
what it the constituents are so lazy
list could as well operate in principle
on databases and columnar structures
there's nothing okay all right that then
you're just taking a different the same
name to mean something different what
i'm talking about here is something
which operates like this giant snake
that has this bulge of operation
somewhere moving down the snake that's
what i that's what the native thing that
i'm understanding your stuff does is
there's a different issue and a
different story which is compiling down
i mean you know if we're listing other
things here we've got things like spark
and hadoop and so on right which are
essentially distributed database
technologies where we're moving
computation down to the database to the
to the data nodes
right so and we also
in that same thing we've got
the arrow stuff right
okay yes but steven i think what i
wanted to say was that lazy list is more
like a list like interface over anything
that can be represented as a list not
necessarily i know i understand that i
understand that that's not what we're
trying
you know it's basically a
one-dimensional thing that's the thing
we're describing here yes you can put
other you know other dimensions as the
elements of that one-dimensional thing
but let's not confuse ourselves
any more than we need to be confused
okay so let's let's keep going here what
other channel technology data bins
yeah that's a good idea that's a good
one
and then there's our own
sort of structured expression things
like like like time series
those are expressive points but that
would be obviously that's a good point
and we've also got
databases temporal data well it sort of
seems like stuff like time series you
would want to be
backed with stuff like this right yes
that's an intimidating quantity arrays
and we want to operate on it with these
tools okay well so there's also what
about the geo data what about our back
end geo data
which is in things like postgres and so
on right
yeah that that's ultimately again sql
well yes it is but it has it has its own
special features i think okay we've also
got sparkle
yeah and that's what i was gonna say in
general graph
databases triple stores
yeah plus triple stores
i mean the the back hand is triple
stores sparkle is just a query language
but yeah i know i know
the
okay all right so now
okay so now we've got kind of places
here
and we've got you know
in memory
we've got
files
in local files
we've got
um cloud
files
we've got cloud expression which is a
little different from cloud files
we've got
um
we've got which we don't yet have but we
will have
um cloud
slash local
uh databases light light where in memory
databases or in file databases that
that's too light and so on
is that right
i'd say process
because they can
i think they're they're embeddable
that's the
that's the main
distinguishing feature for them and file
slash in process but they're stored in
files
not necessarily ask why it can be also
stored in memory
well
it's serialized to a file is it not
yes optionally but you can also say when
you create an sqlite session that you
want it all in memory okay but why would
we care then why do we need that we
don't care about that
why do we why is that relevant it is it
might be a real one because certain
operations even we we might choose at
some point to store things in memory but
uh make uh use of some fast operations
i don't believe in it i think we've got
those operations already for things that
are in memory i think it's more relevant
when we have you know a terabyte size
database and a file
well one example would be indexes for
columns we don't have anything like that
okay but we're going to that's the whole
point of this discussion right so take
that one off the table because it's not
interesting we're going to have that
right so let's not confuse ourselves
but uh stephen uh i think this is like
maybe sqlite is not the thing we're
going to use but probably arrow
is whatever
whatever okay but we don't need this as
a separate place where we're storing
things
okay that's an implementation detail of
what we're doing wait a second stephen i
think there is an important distinction
between in the kernel's memory and in
another processes there is yes there is
right so what are we talking about here
we're talking about we're not talking
about in we're not talking about this
we're talking about local file local
databases local databases using their
own
yeah but but between files
memory
local files you need to add in memory of
another process i that's what i mean
using their own files and memory right
because by the time they're inside our
kernel memory they're just part of our
system and we don't need to discuss them
as something separate right that that's
the in memory case that's what when i
say in memory i mean
in
wl kernel memory
right
make sense
yes do you understand carlo
yeah yeah i agree
okay
okay what other places
so then clearly we have
uh
remotely you know remote sql databases
they're just sitting out there right
that are separately managed that have
whose management has nothing to do with
us
am i making sense
hey come on say please guys you gotta
actually say things okay
yeah okay
all right so
so here's another mode
and that's whether things are
you know
read-only or updatable or deletable so
some of not all of these things
you can delete or or update right
right right i think that's important
read only versus call it crud create
read update delete
yeah i know yeah
right
yeah
right
okay so
and that makes a difference as to what
you know operations okay so we we didn't
mention here our whole entity store
mechanism did we
it should it fits here no right so come
on guys stay awake
you haven't named all these things
what's what's the difference between an
entity store and in memory like that
that is an
oh yeah right the interface is sorry
okay
all right so
again
okay and obviously you know data set is
the i mean again this is this is a bit
of a model what what what should be
where here
but
okay
so where do we go what we were talking
about before was the difference between
mongodb
and
um
so again
i don't know why we're listing these
technologies okay so documents databases
like mongodb
steven
i think one of the reasons why we have
such a long list here is that we are
mixing together things which should fall
into
at least two different categories like
interfaces over things
and things which are kind of a drivers
to certain technologies
okay fine okay so what i'm going to
expect for the next one of these
meetings is that somebody else will try
and make these lists in a more
systematic way
fair scott can you make sure that that
happens yep yep i'll work with you guys
to try to come up with lists
okay so so now
roughly what we're going to be doing
here
uh okay so the question is what does the
overall interface to this look like
so let's imagine that
the the you know the
the overall thing might be data
container
but there are sub cases that might be
you know that might be as small as
method options or as big as their own
heads so to speak
does that make sense
so can we start making a list
so
i want to you know getting back to the
api question
so when we were talking about
you know
scaffolded arrays
then i mean i think what people
think of or the operations people think
of
when they hear array are
extract parts
transposition
well i don't agree with transposition at
all
i i don't agree i think that that's okay
so look the basic api extract parts
possibly
uh right parts so so for example let's
look at cloud expression what api does
it expose
do you understand what i'm saying
stephen yeah i think i know what you're
saying but i i think there are
like at least two big families that have
completely different apis here and the
rectangularish ones and the hierarchical
ones right anything anything you call a
rectangular array i think people would
expect
you know extracting parts remember what
we said at the beginning remember what
we said at the beginning what are we
talking about here
we're talking about rectangular-ish
objects right remember that
large rectangular-ish data that's what
we're talking about but no we're not
talking about something different
cloud expression and [ __ ] are
hierarchical rather than than
rectangular
okay so are they completely separate
you can use [ __ ] in a rectangular way
like the
everybody that is using it in javascript
is actually forcing a schema on on [ __ ]
so it's it can be used that way
is is not an issue it can but it doesn't
it doesn't really necessarily oh
we have got to stay organized in this
conversation right are we talking about
rectangular-ish data or are we talking
about something completely different
so far as i understood what we're
talking about here is rectangular-ish
data that's the only thing we're talking
about i agree but i'm okay so then we've
got different implementation methods if
we think mongodb is irrelevant to
rectangularish data so be it
i don't think it is
anyway
if we don't need it later
right that's what we're talking about
well when you say rectangularist is that
is that necessarily rank two presumably
no absolutely not
absolutely not any rank
no no but for the la most of those that
you listed here they limit to rank two i
don't care we've been through this how
many times do we have to go through the
same thing i don't care do you
understand what i'm saying every time
we're saying the same thing right
certain back ends will be suitable for
things of rank two other ones will be
suitable for higher rank sometimes the
rank two thing can have remote assets
hanging off those elements at rank two
that are higher rank objects
does that make sense so let's cut out
the conversation we
don't need to have that conversation
stephen but if you open cloud expression
which doesn't enforce rectangularity in
any sort of form then we're looking at a
completely different api
like nonsense nonsense do you understand
what i'm saying we are talking here
about life we understand
okay so what i'm saying is cloud
expression is an example of a place
where you can implement large
rectangular-ish data cloud expression
does other things as well but they are
not relevant to our discussion so if you
look at the if you look at the list of
functions and supports these have
nothing to do with rectangular-ish data
these just have to do with expressions
at best append to makes it list like
yeah fine everything else here is
irrelevant i mean okay but fine but then
this is not what's mostly going to be
okay the basic api so this is
the the
so so i think
so when i hear rectangular-ish data i
mean with the
i
i would say transpose is perhaps a bit
of an edge case but certainly if i hear
a ray i think of transpose okay but
that's not what we're mostly dealing
with here we're mostly
there's you know there's part extraction
obviously
and you know there's mapping at the
particular depth
yes yes then there's selecting and
there's doing all those kinds of things
and i think appending prepending adding
to uh is is obviously another one really
important yes
well i i think the question is what is
what does the itch mean i mean how
rectangular does it need to be
well that's what we've been talking
about can i say it again
okay what i mean by that is
that okay we
first point is it fundamentally has a
series of indices
am i making sense
so it isn't the case
for example a graph
is not an example of a rectangular ish
thing
its elements cannot be cannot usefully
be indexed
and yes there are special cases i'm not
interested in grid graphs
right
the in general there are things where
there is a notion of
index indices in a given dimension where
that index is going to range over many
values and where in some sense
there is a outer product of elements
corresponding to different levels does
that make sense to people
for example generalized data set is not
rectangular
so i i would define these as something
that that means some sort of rectangular
hole hull
without many holes
yeah that's right that's what i mean by
this and so with respect to what
christopher is saying i think that
um
the uh
yes a completely general data set with
different creatures hanging in different
places
is not rectangular-ish that is correct
in other words a data set where one
piece of it has a giant association of
associations hanging off it and at the
same level in another part of the data
set is a list of lists of lists that is
not rectangular no no but there's even
other things that are not quite
rectangular like if you have
you know so suppose that uh it's a list
of associations but then within the
association they have two keys and under
one of the keys it's a you know a matrix
and under the other key it's another
layer of associations and it keeps going
that's hierarchical no that's what i was
saying that was the example i was given
that's not rectangular but it does have
a consistent kind of schema but it's not
rectangular i'm just making that clear
well wait a minute what do you mean it
has a consistent schema if the if the
two elements of the association one of
them i mean let's be concrete one of
them
is you know we've got a goes to and then
it's an association here um
okay sure sure shows the values of the
association all up to follow the same
pattern yes yes that's what i'm saying
and then then it's rectangular yes right
so
so okay so this is what we're talking
about everybody agree with this does
anybody want to have and so so what jose
has commented that there's a rectangular
hull
that represents a decent fraction so it
might have some slight raggedness
um
and that raggedness could come in two
forms if it's lists it's always
raggedness quotes at the end if it's
associations it could be raggedness and
key space
does that make sense
oh raggedness in key space should
probably just mean missings
possibly yes yeah okay so then then
the
the rectangular hull
uh is roughly a tight fit
but it can have some holes but there can
be missings and there can be
uh you know
incorrectly length lists
does that make sense to people
so this is the thing we're talking about
here
yes
yes fixing sure
okay all right so then given this
we could store such a thing in a cloud
expression why would we want to do that
we'd want to do that because it's a
convenient way to otherwise we have no
way
to extract
you know the only way to extract a part
of something
if it's an ordinary expression is to
read the whole thing into memory that's
the big thing we get with cloud
expressions we don't have to read it all
into memory now we don't you know if we
don't maintain rectangularity ourselves
the thing could turn into an elephant i
mean it can be any shape
right but that's the special case of
that
now let's go look at some of these other
technologies here and and
uh you know this question of what is the
api
so
you know the api is clearly going to
need to extract parts rate parts it's
clearly going to map over parts
or map over dimensions possibly
making sense well already here we have
to be careful because mapping may change
the types and
you know types is something we kind of
missed in this discussion so far
when we talk about rectangular i think
the notion okay good point good point so
is it is it
is it rectangular there's two kinds of
rectangle is it rectangular in index
space
or in type space
i think type space is even more
important than index space
so let me say something here so i think
the things to assign types to are the
keys of the deepest dimension
in the case of two dimensions that
corresponds to columns but if we had
something of deeper dimension we still
can have types consistently
at the deepest level exactly
so they can vary on that last index only
that would make sense
but then the high level ones are just
aggregations of these types yes
yes but the point is that we cannot
assign a type
at the rows at the levels uh sorry and
at the column simultaneously
okay so you can't say that every element
is the same type because you have
columns with different types of things
i see what you're saying
i see what you're saying so you're
saying union of the different types in
the column
well you can think of it that way if you
want to but but the whole point is that
the column the deepest okay so the basic
point is
for four types
uh
want
as
as as as large a
sort of what can we call it
as as large an index span
as possible to be of uniform type
so for
example eg
a whole
list
or
eg
a whole
2d array
because both of those are are worthwhile
so in the case of the transpose
operation you really want
you know transpose makes sense if you
have an n-dimensional array all of the
same type transpose is pretty weird if
the elements are in other words if if if
all the elements of an n-dimensional
array are the same type you can
transpose to your heart's content
if they are of different types
then transposing will lead to something
which does not have type uniformity down
a column or a
down a column or across a row is that
correct no
if you have something that's consistent
across a column then its transpose will
have consistency across a row which you
know is very useful in you know linear
algebra
yes but but but the problem is that we
cannot represent it if the per if things
are at the deepest level so this happens
already in quantity array and what
happens there is that you don't touch
the data you just store the permutation
you transpose
right when you are going to extract
something you undo the permutation but
you cannot transpose the data
so we can see examples with quantity
however you want
what do you mean you cannot transpose to
data
see i mean you you
right i mean
certainly it i mean
maybe as some implementation detail you
can't transpose the data but you can
certainly right i can take the normal of
both the original guy and the transpose
guy and i see something that's an array
with either consistent units in the
column or consistent units in a row
and so i don't understand what you're
saying i can't
i can't transpose the data
if we are assigning the types to the
deepest level as you transpose the
deepest level to the highest level
then you have a problem in the
representation
if you're normalized it's all fine but
there are the compact representation is
not adapted anymore
is that just because the quantity array
only lets you specify types like uh by
column or something right
at the deepest level it can be it can
yeah
so when your generalized column to
switch with your rows then it you can't
yeah yeah
right
but i still don't understand why that
needs
why that's a fundamental restriction and
not an implementation detail of quantity
array okay i'm not sure let's let's
let's not cover that right now okay
then okay just and i really want to see
rob's threaded demonstration so but what
we what we're seeing here
let's just define what we have to get
here we need a better list
of these
you know back ends technologies
storage places formats etc
okay
then
we need
the
the kind of the different levels of api
the different kinds of operations that
we might do on these rectangular ish
data objects please don't confuse things
which are general expression cop
you know computations that are not
relevant to rectangularish data
make sense
yes
and
then
let's see what we want to do here
um
okay so so then
the goal is
as we talked about before
we've got the underlying data
representation and we've got the wrapper
the wrapper is the thing that is the
translation layer
okay so so actually we've got we've got
several different concepts here we've
got the underlying data representation
well i mean okay so let's just just list
something for sort of architecture
um
we've got sort of
connect can i before you move on to
architecture cast something about this
rectangular ish definition
um
except the last are generalizing could
be strings
instead of numbers of course of course
they could be of course they can be
that's the point of associations
yeah so of course
so at that point basically you could
always
you cannot just have random gunk in
these high-level industries say i didn't
say random jump what i'm saying is that
if you have something where you have
three dimensions and the first two are
like first name and last name
then
then you don't have a rectangular array
period end of story
if those are you know smith jones
whatever and they're completely
different in other words if they're i
mean if the whole point is it's an outer
product type idea
the eyes form a collection of possible
keys the j's form a collection of
possible keys it is the the you know the
overall key for an array element
is based on an outer product
of those key lists
does that make sense
yeah i'm just saying what i'm describing
is a bit more ragged but it's i know i'm
saying it's not included
that's not what we're going after we're
going after the case where the each one
of the indices has a certain set of
possible values
and the possible
you know indexing of a single element is
the outer product of the li of the sets
associated with each of the individual
indices
does anybody have a problem with that
definition it seems to me
it's very it's clean
it also means that you have basically a
list of of what those indices are or
keys are
in that outer product
yeah that's what's yeah the thing is
that it's true
it's irrelevant
we don't want to do that case we're
doing the case we're describing here we
are not doing the generalization of that
because guess what if we do the
generalization of that we cut down i
mean it just why do you think we should
do that generalization because that's
the shape that uh that real data takes
in the outside world and that's why it's
usually you basically what you do is
like you have more people
nonsense
it's just nonsense you're
misunderstanding what we're talking
about we're not saying that okay so here
the index here is first name or last
name not the actual smith jones names
right the index
that the thing
maybe i'm misunderstanding something can
anybody else help me here i think carlos
is is you know talking
what i'm saying is that it is common
that
you have multiple keys that together
form an unique thing
and so you can slices and dice it as
many in as many ways as you want but in
general it's still stored as a
bi-dimensional thing so they together
they form a unique identifier identifier
but you can take all the people who have
last name wolf from all the people who
have first name steven
it's only they're not unique so what are
you talking about
why is that relevant to this data
representation because this is what
people store data anybody anybody else
wanted to jump in and understand what's
going on here i don't understand this i
i don't understand what carlo is saying
but my impression is that whenever you
have a list of keys you can declare an
index that runs over those keys
exactly
and then and then you are in in this
framework again it's just one of these
industries
you have no requirement that if there is
a carlos
steven barbieri somewhere
are you talking about this sort of the
value basically yeah i think it is
are you talking about the values i'm
talking about the keys what i'm saying
is that
multiple indices it doesn't really
matter that they're full
it's a sparse representation of the same
thing
it's like a sparse association ends up
being b dimensional anyway
it's more general it looks more like
i think this is not what we're doing
okay so let me give a concrete example
here what you're saying is x arrow
you know list a wait a minute one b
two
here okay now
you're saying
then
in
the in the world of rectangularity
we would say y goes to the same kind of
thing right
that's what we
think we mean by basic rectangularity
what you're saying is
instead here
let's call this p
and and q for example right that's the
case you're talking about correct colu
yes there is an operation where you
basically can flatten the indices and
have xa
i i understand that i understand let's
get straight what you're talking about
okay the difference between what we were
saying before which is to say it is an
outer product of index sets
this is the case where it's an outer
product of index sets yes
does that make sense
okay this is the case where it's not an
outer product of index sets
okay so in the previous definition of
rectangularity we are excluding cases
like this
right
yes do you understand yes
okay now you are objecting to excluding
cases like this
is that right
yeah
okay so let's understand that
so
in
in a strict definition of rectangularity
this is excluded
okay i i would say we can have the
possibility of a union of keys and then
have some heuristic parameter
it's it's a bit like a sparseness we
allow
some
such percentage of sprites so so so now
let's take the intermediate case where
we also have a goes to seven here
and and where we might say well we can
just take the the union of all the keys
right but now carlo is making a
different point i believe which is to
say that is there an operation we have
for doing this that turns this into x a
x b
y p p y q q right
as keys
yeah
okay so it's one dimensionalizing this
thing
okay big deal i mean sure we can
certainly do that but i don't think
that's critical to what we're talking
about what we're talking about is the
native data structure that we're dealing
with here is a rectangular-ish array
and you're saying we can transform this
thing which is not a rectangular-ish
array to a one-dimensional quotes
rectangular-ish array by essentially
compressing across that that there's two
dimensions of keys
is that correct yeah my general point
was that any sparsish
multi-dimensional thing can be
represented as a rectangular
two-dimensional thing by
union in the keys
and so why is it two-dimensional what
what why is that a convenient thing to
do i mean what jose was saying is
there's a sort of a heuristic of down to
what
you know if what we have efficiently
implemented is rectangular-ish array
operations then for sure things which
are not rectangular-ish we might want to
by virtue of the wrapper
turn into something
rectangular-ish in other words that to
me that's a that's a responsibility of
the rapper to figure out how given the
native underlying representation which
we are agreeing is rectangular-ish
how do we translate the actual form into
that into that to uh you know in into
that format
so similarly if we had a quantity array
and we've transposed a quantity array so
that you know
random elements are in are in feet or or
seconds
we don't really have a good situation
you know our wrapper has to contain tons
of information about how element 17 is
in feet element 18 is in seconds
so to speak that is not a good
rectangular issue
but that's why i was saying to them like
the example you're showing here is
basically each of those is just a single
row
and then then you repeat that multiple
times but what i'm saying is that
like each suppose you have first name
and last name
each person then which is identified the
first and last name can have
uh different ages can have like it can
have one age sorry it can have an
address it can have all sorts of things
yes those are uniform in type but
they're indexed by two things name and
last first name whatever i don't see why
that i don't see why that's a big deal
i don't understand what i'm trying to
demonstrate is that the most general
case is still the one that is
two-dimensional although the other one
no it's not reflexive yes of course it
can but that's not relevant
we're not going to represent everything
in two dimensions yes you could in
principle represent everything in a
database in an sql database with just
one table
no foreign keys nothing just one table
you've squashed it into that but guess
what many operations will be
unbelievably inefficient in that form so
we're not interested in that
and i would say what's special about two
dimensions why not compress everything
into one dimensions at that point
yeah it just doesn't make any sense it's
just a you know yeah okay so let's again
let's go back to our definitions
we are imagining there are
rectangular-ish things and no they will
not all fit in two dimensions if we
insist that we're going to use an sql
database then we will have to squash
them into two dimensions at the cost of
great decrease in efficiency for certain
kinds of objects
but otherwise our general definition is
arbitrary dimensional rectangular-ish
things
where there is translation in the
there's essentially an address
translation layer which is the wrapper
it's more than just a dress translation
it's also element wrapping with things
like quantities and so on does that make
sense to people
yep
and and that wrapper might also take
care of taking dates let's say which
might be stored in some native you know
single number format and it turns them
into data objects and things like this
except steven it might be
uh what you are calling a wrapper might
be a kind of a scheme
with certain type uh you know uh
transforms so
it might be not necessarily for a single
element it might be some kind of
metadata that instructs how you convert
the types oh i agree i agree no that's
what i would imagine the whole point of
the wrapper is the wrapper is something
which is bulk a bulk description of what
to do with lots of elements if the
rapper has to individually address every
element
the wrapper is the data and it's and
you've lost the game
exactly
right so
you know but but the point and that's
why for example if there is that's what
jose's definition of slight deviations
from rectangularity that is something
you know the wrapper can handle you know
10 missings in a million data elements
by the time it's three-quarters of a
million missings
then it's not a good representation
because then you've got three quarters
of a million objects in the wrapper
in the address translation table
effectively
does that make sense to people i mean
so okay so i think we've got an outline
of what we're trying to do here that is
and so one of the other
objectives will be
to figure out what are the operations
what are the native operations that we
can expect might be doable on this
rectangular-ish array
okay and those will include the
operations that we have
for relational database up type
operations
like the sorted entity classes of this
world and so on right guys
yeah okay so let's make a list of all of
those
and then for some types of
back ends some of those will be
difficult to support for example all the
ones associated with writing will be
unsupportable in the case where the
where the back end is read only
does that make sense
that makes sense you know there's
another thing we haven't quite thought
about and that is whether it mutates
whether these things are mutable or not
like expressions are not
in most senses mutable so that's another
way of thinking about the operations
just oh yes that's a good point that is
a good point that's uh that's maybe we
should have names consistent names for
mutating like we have a pen too but
maybe we should see like map we could
have map
in
which is like mutating and map which is
not mutating
well map is kind of map your map no no
no no no map in would like mutate and
map would i i got it i got it i got it i
got it i got it so but i mean it's a
little bit confusing because the second
argument here so that's the that's the
um
or map too i don't know or select you
see you could have select that would
mutate or not mutate right right right
right right
of course if you just have fold and
things like that it's not a problem
what do you mean
well folds doesn't
fold doesn't mutate fold just
does you know
iterates across the thing and yeah
right actually fold is returning is is
doing the reduce as opposed to the map
so to speak
right you don't
the case where you are interested in
mutation is where you are going to leave
the basic structure the same
right
modifying the the the
mutation is relevant
no no i i understand that tom but
there's a different point mutation is
relevant and worthwhile
i.e worthwhile
when it sprinkles operations
across
an existing
structure
in other words ie
i eeg
it's useful
for map
it's less it's not useful
for fold
because fold is just taking everything
yeah yeah right yeah now the function
that's being folded might mutate but
yeah what you're saying too
yes
right but so maybe there's a different
operation which is a general mutation
operation
in which
what you're doing i think the mutation
is a headdress thing
right so what it is is something like
um
okay so i'm going to claim it something
like this
mutate of map
of okay so we've got expert here
which is essentially the handle to exper
and we've got
okay i'm going to claim it something
like this
because map has a curried form so it can
just do that
right there's a general mutate operation
that says
this thing here
this is this is essentially i mean this
is equivalent to
expert equals map
f on to expo
and i'm i'm saying i think there might
be a way of factoring that so that you
have a mutation operation like this
which takes as one argument the function
that is the mutator
i would expect that mutation is
particularly useful when you have to
change only a few parts of the whole
expression
and therefore add functions like re
place it's also just part of the culture
of the technology that you're working
with
i think that's that's okay
fine but do you understand what i'm
saying if we want to have a top-level
interface we do not want to have 300
functions that are mutation variants of
functions we already have
are making sense
yes
so
you know right now we have a limited
number of functions that show basically
assignments and things like append to
and so on which are mutation oriented
functions
and most of our functions like map at
doesn't have a mutation form
by the way isn't that thing you wrote
with mutate identical to the
slash slash equals
oh my cursor is on right now
right i was just going to
bring that what is what is okay slash
slash equals is is this like multiply
two
so that's you say it's equivalent to
this
the fact it's also called apply to is is
uh notable maybe
yes that is notable so you're saying
like this
i meant
oh no i see i see yes yes yes
so what i need to say is expert equals
abc
and then i say this
and then i say what's expert and it's
that beautiful
right but i guess this is really just
the precedences i mean
chaining these is pretty painful i mean
maybe unless the precedence is sort of
strange but i mean maybe maybe
i i think it would be more natural if
there's like a headdress or something
than expecting people to really write
this
when when their data is like
yeah
like if you're dealing with a database
where where you you know you have to do
mutable operations or something like
that you can't map and copy then i think
asking people to write it like this is
kind of nuts
all right let's have a very quick i'm
late for something else but let's have a
very quick demo of the threading stuff
rob are you ready for that
well jose has a notebook
okay are you going to oh oh you say i
can do it because i'm yeah you should
just be able to do it
okay
exactly in the x corner okay i'm in the
x kernel
oh that's really old
yeah you need to oh
well so somebody else needs to
this is wrong can somebody let roger
know i don't know why this is not
updated
you could just show your
notebook which was got that quite nice
call it roger now
i can try this one instead
let me just try see if i can run it
myself
no it still sings 13-0 and right
i think probably forgot to update the
prototype to grab 13-1 instead of 13-0
bad okay
all right so somebody else who would
like to demo uh i can do it
yeah that would be great
okay
okay so let me check that they have yes
so so this is how it works we have this
array
and if we do thread it here
then um sorry to remove this stuff
and then you see we get that's lovely oh
it's it's the the broadcasting nice yep
and this works also for cases of deeper
uh dimensions so
something like this
let me understand this so threaded by
default is looking at the other thing
with the plus operator and it's going to
the deepest level so if you if you take
that first expression
and you say plus threaded of cd
no in other words a ternary plus oh i
see you'll add in a plus threaded of cd
yeah
magnificent yeah it must really use this
level of the unbreaded part
i mean okay so now now just for fun
could you say five six seven
in um
in there
so that's gonna error out right exactly
correct exactly okay all right okay fine
okay but put back remove the seven again
just so we have something that works
okay
okay that's out of curiosity does does
it also um
i don't know if we ever actually fully
designed these but this is the second
arguments of threaded or the second and
third i think it will just can't do that
christopher i have thought
i think i know possibly how to do it
um but you know i'm doing some other
stuff i took a break from it to
to let it jail for a bit but but i think
it's might be possible to do that but so
just to review what that is right now
we've got two cases if you have the
naked plus with the stability it will go
on level one it will try and thread at
level one
this will try and thread at the deepest
level
the alternative is to thread at level n
correct correct
which is
sorry jose can you try adding plus efg
at the end
right so we have both threaded and not
threaded
yes that that works as well
that's lovely it's really nice
okay so so just to understand here the
operation that this is equivalent to in
terms of maps and so on there is some
mappy version of this that for level n
is the identi you know there's some
theorem that says this is equal to
something involving map is that true
so i would say this is a thread
at a particular level and i was
i was defending that we should have map
thread work with negative levels and
then it would be like i see then that's
just like this one
yeah
right that makes sense
yeah so that's the thing i was
definitely here
always equivalent to building an array
filling it out to an array of the right
shape and then adding them as you know
fully formed arrays
it's it's always doable like that i
think that that was like etienne's
prototype worked like that but i i
thought the point of this is that it
could be way more efficient no no i no
no i'm just saying if you're gonna as an
explanatory model
oh yeah
yep say that again roger
you can always that thread at a b
you can build a matrix
oh i see
you know it is a b b a b a b yeah repeat
the same shape yes right and then it's
just normal matrix addition there's
nothing funky
and but but i think it's a good
explanatory model to to to do
right so in other words the threaded is
the equivalence of repeating the
appropriate number of times to fill it
in to be the same shape as the first
thing yes
yes that is the discussion of
replication we have is it yeah
this is lovely or maybe if you want to
look at it with map
the efg is map
plus with the at level one and the
threaded ab is met plus at level two
yes okay let's see some more here what
did you have about a raisin associate
okay so this next one here
is saying we're taking that
and each one of those is being
um could you could you write out just
could you just do in that
initial
yes heck is the array shape just just
just make it just do the command shift
whatever to make the array reshape in
place there just so we see what it's
actually operating on
uh sorry x form so this is an array
of these dimensions four three two and
the point that we want to make here is
that this has
to have the dimensions at the deepest
levels but it can be several of them
right so just for my benefit could you
do the same thing
but instead of that do threaded just
threaded a b
and make a copy of that make it here
um yeah just okay so then that's going
to just cookie that's going to replicate
itself across all of those things and
then do that
magnificent so i guess for the case the
one case that that that isn't handled
yet is the uh thread of a threaded of
abc
right that that's right
level at the higher level which would
then do is it clear what that does i
think it is clear what that does
is it clear what that does i don't think
i mean here that we have unique
dimensions maybe but right what if there
were multiple threes in there
right i mean no no no no no no no no no
no no it's it's the dimension two i mean
it's like dimension it's level two that
this level
three is irrelevant but but the question
is is it is it clear what
at level okay if we did the plus
yeah i see it is clear what to do it is
clear so so then what would happen is
some of these would plus c's you know
some of them would plus a b c
going across
that top row there it would be the first
thing would be uh 1 1 plus a 2 plus a
three plus b four plus b five plus c six
plus c is that correct
yeah
does that actually work
no yeah i think
i'm lost but are you discussing whether
this should end up adding no no
absolutely not nobody thinks it should
nobody thinks it should what we're
thinking so make a copy of that input
line
the
right there's some second argument right
either minus two or plus two in this
case yes i see i see
yes so this is the idea of i was
saying here of of map threading at the
level -2 and then it would do what you
are expecting
right but we could also say level two
here correct
in this particular case
it's just saying the second index
or the index two from the end
right so then
what that matters is with ruggedness
precisely because if we have something
like one two
uh let's say something like this and
then two three exactly the minus two and
the plus two will not be in the same
place exactly if we generalize to
ruggedness then we have a
different choice here well here let's do
that do that with the thread of this and
see what that does i i think this is
failing right now
okay but what do you think
i don't think there's a problem that
that fails right now
right i mean in other words it could
i i yeah i really don't think it's a
problem just like stability won't work
if it isn't if the you know dimensions
don't conform
yes so i i think the right thing to do
here is to have a way of specifying from
outside by differentiating positive and
negative levels and then you know from
which side to count
yes well i mean so you're saying
threaded might actually need a more
complicated specification that says
pick either minus two or plus two or
whatever it might be i see so the only
thing that's well defined is it's a
uniform dimensional object on the left
and the threaded
i think it's it's well defined if it's a
uniform dimensional object just having
the plus minus
level on the threaded is well defined
right the second case that in this case
the 432 case that you've got here
then it's well defined
it's only if that thing is ragged if the
thing if that first argument is ragged
there's a problem i think
yes but i think what i was discussing is
whether we should have he has positive
or negative signs i think they should
mean different things they do mean
different things yes they should mean
different things but they they mean
different things with respect to the
four three two indices like minus one
would be the the
see
and plus one would be the top level but
it doesn't you know if there's
raggedness i don't know how whether we
can define that i see i see what you
mean yes
i i wouldn't do the raggedness initially
i would just punt as you have done here
and maybe we can have some some future
meaning for it but i don't think it's
the most important thing right now
this this octagonal thing with with the
with the full thing is super useful for
uh data science already this will cover
a lot of cases yeah i know about the
ruggedness
it's actually not as inefficient as i
thought now you know
that's nice to hear well good
it unpacks to one level if you say add a
big matrix to a packed array
with threaded buttons
i'm going to count on you to keep it as
packed as possible
but let's see jose did you have it yeah
that's okay
okay so i assume this works with any
listable function so you could have used
arctan instead of plus there
yes in fact you can define what i did to
demonstrate is i i set up a function i
said gave it the attribute listable and
you can see where the indexes are going
really easily there
yes yeah yeah out of curiosity just just
to you know the pushing it further like
um does it uh what about like
associations
that jose and i are thinking about and
that that goes back to the scaffolding
stuff
okay can you show us what roughly what
you have in mind here so right now with
an association if i say plus three to an
association it will
uh listably thread down to the elements
of the association correct
they don't think so they don't think
listability try it try it try it i think
it does i think it does i think it does
too
try it just just type in association
you know some trivial
okay so now say outside the whole thing
just say plus seven or something
or x
yeah yeah it works fine okay
and whatever remember there is some
subtlety about listable functions and
associations but
yeah maybe maybe oh maybe it's when you
have a combination of lists and
associations that i'm sure is hopeless
well no i i think it gets more
complicated when you start adding when
the seven is itself an association and
you're trying to line up the keys of
them but it does work it does work and i
think it assumes that just try that with
a and c as the second association
um i see
it does work iterates through the
associations to check them for
compatibility
okay now try this
right but if it was a and b then i think
it would work right even if the left one
was and maybe if you put the left one in
a list
just to make it even harder like the
left association in the list i mean
oh i think
yeah yeah
sure
right
what is that doing
it's the other point being if you had a
if you had a big list of it it's the
same as with lists it's the same
behaviors with lists right it first
threaded over the list and it threaded
over the assistant oh i see i see i get
it yeah
right but the associations have to be
um have to be alignable so to speak
yeah yes and i bet have to be identical
and like i try um if you reverse the
order of one of those associations it'll
probably break right yeah
yeah
okay
this is quite lovely oh i i okay i
looked it up the issue i was thinking of
there was a question of when you have a
list an association who wins
and the answer is the list wins
but
i see it which is threaded over first
yeah
this is great i mean what are the bells
and whistles and we should wrap this
meeting in a moment what are the bells
and whistles are we imagining for
threaded
well possibly possibly some
non-rectangularity
and possibly this second argument
i think the second argument is worth is
important and doesn't sound too hard to
implement i would not worry so much
about non-rectangularity
okay fine and then then the next the
next bells and whistles are you know
easy but it's the most work
and that's making it work with um
you know packed arrays
yeah
seems very important and the name
threaded how are you feeling about the
name threaded
it's not obviously horrible
rob rob let's make it work in the
compiler
then use that
right exactly tom that's
you know i think threaded is not i agree
that threaded is not terrible but
i'm not sure it conveys
quite the right meaning it would be
lovely if it was shorter
oh
okay to be thought about
i mean
i'm sorry one side question and uh um
that does it maybe this was certainly a
previous meeting where it wasn't here it
doesn't make sense to have something
that does the same thing but from the
outside
that's most
yeah
with different threading or when you put
the plus in and and you do the thing
okay so this this method generalization
with negative spec that jose was talking
about basically
i think we'll just do that yeah so i i
was defining that it should be this
right okay
what what do people think of the name at
depth
i don't yeah i don't
yeah
i'm not into that
at depth as in as in like it's a catfish
it's it's swimming on the bottom of the
ocean
right it's it's it's right in the single
argument form it's at the deepest level
and then if you want to
specify at what depth it's swimming then
you give it a strand but i think the the
case we really want to name is the it's
going along the bottom of the ocean
right it's a flounder or something yeah
bottom feeder the deepest
i think that's just utterly obscure to
say deepest um
because i think what the question is how
are people thinking about this they're
thinking about it as
i mean what we have first i think about
it in terms of array levels so deepest
makes perfect sense to me but i know but
you're thinking about the indices maybe
that's that's from your life in general
relativity
that he says but
but then the level argument we said may
come as well and then that's no more
deepest
i understand so we don't want the word
deepest in there
even though it is a good contrast with
the stability
um
exactly
that that's where i was coming from
right
yeah but the question is
right i understand what but what people
will think about here
is
i want to add i've got a list of vectors
i want to
add something to the x coordinate and
the y coordinate of each vector
and i want to do that for a list of
vectors what would you call that
operation
well in many languages plus
i i i know i know other languages so
we really
we want something that
basically disables listability
because we want vector variables
okay and so it's a separate topic isn't
it i think it's basically the same
headdress it just says disable it
okay that's it okay that's a good topic
roger let's pick that up another time
right okay because i know you need that
you need something where you can do a
plus and where it's a list a b plus
this thing which symbolically represents
a vector v plus a b
where
you've got so that's a good point so
what you've what you've got then
is on the one hand you've got threaded
which is saying i want to insert myself
as a vector at the lowest level on the
other hand you have v plus list a b
where you want v to say i'm not actually
i look like
i'm a
bottom level object well we have just
actually not
we have sort of a very simple automatic
type system in mathematica that thinks
that a symbolic variable is a scalar
yes i know i know so what you want you
want something that overrides that yeah
right so this one overwrites listability
we want to overwrite listability in a
different way
another thing we call this in images is
interleaved
that's another concept
that's a nice name
that's a type of transposition
actually bob on our live stream suggests
inject
injected
it's not terrible
it's not terrible we should make a note
of that please because i think that's an
interesting concept
of
but what roger is asking v plus list a b
we should talk about that next time what
rapper you can put around the v
to say i don't want to be
caught up in the stability
right
right i mean it's almost like thread at
zero or something but
but
but it's not i mean
it's like a whole it's like a hold the
stability right we do it now but it's
really not great it's right so let's
enact plus
that's horrible it's absolutely horrible
yeah let's discuss it next time i know
okay so look we've got two branches here
we've got the threaded discussion which
i think looks to me to be completely
separate from the discussion about back
end
you know data containers so let's break
this into two separate meetings one
about threaded and one about back-end
data containers and the threaded
discussion probably could be pretty much
merged into an ild discussion
um up to up to you guys to do that
all right well this has been productive
um
i really like this threaded thing and so
does several people on our live stream
so
this is a winner
um even if its name is not yet
settled um i mean i think it's going to
fit into the splice nothing etc family
somehow rather similar to the splice
idea
note that splice is called splice not
spliced
i know
but that's because spice is a noun
as a splice of a
i never interpreted it as a noun
either
i wrote a long discussion about this
well okay fair enough
all right okay let's wrap this up thanks
a lot guys
oh actually somebody's suggesting
stitched
somebody should write that down
i've got the list of suggestions i'll
forward it